Mitt Romney says George Santos doesn't
deserve to serve in Congress because
he's a liar okay fine yeah he is a liar
he's got all these sorts of shady things
in his past it's kind of like a lame
joke at this point that that lame jokes
can be funny for a little bit and then
they become really really unfunny and
then they get really really funny again
that's the Arc of the of weak jokes
that's how I feel about George Santos
that he got elected and I liked that he
got elected school that a republican got
elected in Long Island and then I
started to not like him because it
turned out he's lied about everything
his education his professional
background probably his sexual desires
he might be under indictment in Brazil
or something I saw a headline about that
and then but then the more that came out
the the more that came out I thought no
this is freaking hilarious I I now get a
huge kick out of this guy if the
Democrats get their eccentric figures
okay fine George Santos is there we have
a razor thin majority anyway I get a
huge kick out of it